Okay.
Why don't we get started?
This is a very special session for
a number of reasons. For me personally, it's a special session
because it combines two organizations that I think
are leading the world right now, the AACR and Cancer Grand
Challenges.
I think and I hope-- I'm program chair this year of the
annual meeting, shared with Alice Shaw, and we tried
very hard to talk about how science goes all the
way from mechanism to benefit for patients.
And what's happening in the Cancer Grand Challenges program is exactly
that. I think in this world right now,
the potential for making a difference in patients' lives is
unprecedented, and the headwinds that we face in cancer
research are also unprecedented.
And there are really two beacons of light in the world right now, the
AACR and Cancer Grand Challenges CRUK.
So it's a particular pleasure to see them coming together
for this session. Just a couple of words about this session before I
turn it over to the chair,
Charlie Swanton.
I was always struck by the quote from Francis Galton,
Darwin's cousin, of nature versus nurture.
Talk about a quote that has created problems
for quite a long time. It's remarkable to think about
putting those two things in opposition.
And everything we've learned about genetics and epigenetics talks
about how our DNA responds to the outside world.
And yet,
the ability to think about what that actually means for getting cancer and for
treating it has lagged behind. I think the work that you're going to hear
about today in this session is really game-changing
in thinking about the interplay between the
environment and our genomes, and how that affects the development
of cancer and its progression, and what it actually means for everything from
thinking about what mutations mean and do, to what are the factors
that promote tumors, to how we detect and treat these cancers.
So I think you're in for an extraordinary session.
It's a treat, and I can't wait to listen. Charlie.
Thank
you. Thank you very much, Paul, for the excellent introduction.
So I just want to tell you a little bit about the Cancer Grand
Challenges and this special session. So I'm Charlie Swanton.
I work at the Francis Crick Institute, and I'm also delighted to
say I'm also chair of the scientific committee of the Cancer Grand Challenges,
which gives us an incredible opportunity every two years to see the
extraordinary discovery research that's going on globally,
in fields very relevant to the disease we all study.
Today, we're going to hear from these four eminent speakers,
who have all been part or have led or are leading
key Grand Challenge teams, reporting back to us
today on their seminal findings that are really breaking the
barriers of understanding this disease at a scale, I think it's fair to
say, when we first started the CGC back in 2020, we could not
have imagined.
So where are we now? Well, we
now span funding across 19
countries, and one of the beauties about this NCI/Cancer Research UK
initiative is that this is true global research.
This is funding that spans international borders and
boundaries, bringing the very best labs together from across
the world to understand and make new discoveries
in this disease. We're funding over 1,800 investigators.
We've tackled 18 challenges. We have presence in over
100 research institutes. To date, we've committed
£464 million, well over half a billion
dollars.
And we really want to identify the toughest challenges.
We want to
set challenges that, if successful, will enable us to
rethink and reimagine this disease.
And we want to, obviously, harness the collective power of a global community.
And I think for all of us here who've run labs, one of the biggest frustrations,
apart from getting successful grants, is getting successful grants
that cross international boundaries.
And that
specific challenge is something I think that NCI and the CRUK
together in this really successful partnership, have done a
tremendous job of enabling. So I'm
sorry about this slide. It's busy, but this illustrates the 36
challenges that we funded,
or that we set, I should say,
over the last six or seven or so years.
You can see we span the sort of breadth of the disease.
We're going to be hearing from four of those today.
And
I'm excited about what we will hear from Mike and Alan,
Karen and Eileen,
elucidating the various aspects of the Grand Challenges.
I'll introduce one by one in a minute.
Now,
where are we and how do we think about sort of the layout of the land, if you
like, of the Cancer Grand Challenge portfolio?
I think it's quite helpful to think
really about the very first cells or the very last cell and thinking
about the impact those cells have, both within their micro environments
and in their macro environment. So we've had a very strong
focus on
mutagenic carcinogens,
tumor initiation,
and from Alan Balmain's work and Mike Stratton's work in
mutographs, this has led directly to a second grand challenge, PROMINENT,
which is studying the role of tissue inflammation combined with
pre-initiated
dormant or progenitor cells with somatic oncogenic
mutations.
And then we've funded 3D spatial analyses to
better understand how tumors evolve within a human body
at the spatial level, both proteomically and transcriptomically.
And then we've had ongoing and successful grand challenges,
E-Dynamic, which Paul is leading, which has really revolutionized, I think it's
fair to say, our understanding of extrachromosomal
DNAAnd we've got a very strong focus on
immunology and pediatric malignancies, as shown here.
NextGen, for example, is pioneering
CAR T therapies in pediatric patients.
And we're trying to elucidate nature's rule books
around the TCR-MHC antigen interactions to see if we
can better predict which antigens T cell receptors recognize.
And then last but not least, is something that I've been very excited about really
since the inception of the Grand Challenges, which is thinking about cancer as a
disease of the whole body. And you'll be hearing from
Eileen later talking about their extraordinary work in the field of
cancer cachexia, which is really unraveling the interplay between the
central nervous system and the cancer and vice versa, and
how appetite, apathy,
anhedonia, and other aspects that many of the clinicians in the audience will be
familiar with sort of managing in the clinic, how
they manifest systemically and at a
mechanistic level.
And also, doing some wonderful work describing the landscape of
cachexia, which
turns out to be a lot more complex than perhaps we ever imagined.
So you'll be hearing from all of those teams.
And without further ado, I just want to say one other thing,
which is before we get started, at the end of this session, there will be drinks,
which I understand are going to be here.
David, am I right in saying that?
Drinks afterwards. So please
think about staying behind and having a chat with the
teams who will stay behind to answer your questions as well.
And I can see many of you in the audience who aren't speaking today who are also
members of CGC teams. So I hope you'll stay behind as well, and you
can meet the leadership, David Scott and Lorenzo, who can answer
all of your questions about how the Grand Challenge is run, what our plans might be
over the next few years for the next set of questions, and anything else you fancy
asking us. We're here to help, and we're very excited about this initiative.
And I will say something before the Q&A about all the
other funders. We've got many funders who've collaborated with us over the years,
who continue to collaborate with us, and have made the Grand Challenge what it is.
It's not just the NCI and Cancer Research UK, but we depend
very heavily on the generosity of philanthropic foundations,
private funders, as well as national charities and funders
that have supported us over the last six years.
So without further ado, we'll get stuck into the first talk.
What we're going to do is have four 15-minute talks, followed by a panel discussion
where we'll bring all the speakers up here afterwards.
So we'll just sequentially go through the talks one by one and
save questions for the end. So please do stay to the end and ask
questions. So first of all, first and foremost is Sir Mike
Stratton,
who completed his Mutagraphs program
about a year and a half ago. He was
former director of the Wellcome Sanger Institute, and he's currently a senior group
leader there. Mike trained initially in medicine, specializing
in histopathology. And as many of you, I'm sure pretty much all of
you know, his primary research interests have been in the genetics and genomics of
cancer,
undertaking seminal work in the discovery of BRCA2,
BRAF activating mutations in melanoma, to name just
a few. But of course, over recent years, he's
really unraveled spectacular
orchestration of the cancer genome
at a nucleotide level, describing in really
intense detail
the origins of mutagenic signatures, which you'll hear about today, and their
impact on cancer
geographically. Of course, he's received many awards,
deservedly. He was elected fellow of the Academy of Medical Sciences in
1999, fellow of the Royal Society in 2008, and
elected to EMBO membership in 2009.
And I think he's just been awarded the Jesse Stevenson
Kovalenko Medal for his transformative work in cancer genomics from
the National Academy of Sciences, deservedly.
Mike, it's a great pleasure to introduce you.
Would you like to come and give your talk?
Thank you very much for that very generous introduction, Charlie, and
thank you very much to Cancer Grand Challenges for asking me to
be here to represent the work that the Mutagraphs team did over a
period of essentially eight years.
Now, from the original challenge that was set to us by
the
Grand Challenges team, we reshaped that into
this primary aim of Mutagraphs, which was
to advance understanding of the causes of cancer through the
patterns of somatic mutation that are found in normal and cancer
cell genomes.
And that was motivated by really the
findings of epidemiologists, which is that there is
international variation in the incidence of almost all solid
cancer types, which indicates that something of the order of
80% of cases are caused by lifestyle or environmental
exposures.
However, only half of these cases are explained
by known carcinogen exposures or risk factors,
which essentially means that there are causes of
cancer remaining to be discovered, and it's important to discover
those because that is what enables us to prevent cancer.
But
no new causes of cancer have been recently
identified by conventional epidemiological
approaches.So alternative
strategies would be helpful. And one alternative
strategy is to examine body tissues for the
biological footprints of past carcinogen exposures.
After all, a carcinogen must do something to the tissues which
ultimately leads to cancer. It must leave some sort of mark.
And if we can detect those marks, that's a starting point for
identifying, for knowing that there has been a carcinogen exposure
there. And then if one can detect those
footprints to work back from them to identify the
specific agent that might have caused them, and then to walk forward
from those footprints to estimate the cancer risk that they would be
associated with.
Now, of course, the changes in patterns of somatic mutation
that are present in normal and cancer cell genomes, these
are footprints of past carcinogen exposures.
They're particularly useful footprints because they're permanent once they've
been established, so you can expect to find them even if you look
for
them 50 years after they've been generated.
And of course, they're also responsible directly for the
carcinogenic effects of the carcinogen.
So the looking for such patterns, which was the
prompt of the original challenge, came at a very good moment
because this was a period around 2015
when the sequencing of whole cancer genomes had gathered
momentum, so large amounts of data, large numbers of
mutations were being generated from substantial numbers of
cancers. And that's what enabled one to
extract, to ascertain these patterns of
mutations that are there. And those patterns were called mutational
signatures, each of which is caused by an underlying mutational
process.
And those mutational signatures can be generated either by endogenous
mutational processes. We all, as we live, we generate
mutations, and also by the mutational
processes that we're particularly interested in in this context, which is the
exogenous exposures.
All genomes carry mutations from multiple mutational signatures,
so they have to be separated from each other.
And at that time, in the middle of about 2015,
the theoretical ways of doing that, the conceptual and
operational, computational, and mathematical approaches were put in place,
which allowed one to extract mutational signatures.
And this is a mutational signature.
The patterns were pretty familiar, but I'll just go through.
You can see there the six types of base substitution,
C to A, C to G, C to T, T to A, T to C, and T to G.
But the classification of base substitutions that we use is elaborated
from there. We include the base immediately before the mutated
base and the base after the mutated base, and that leads to a
classification of 96 different base substitutions,
which are represented there as a 96 bar chart.
And in this particular mutational signature, most of the mutations
are blue, so they're C to A mutations.
And that pattern has been associated with tobacco
smoke chemicals, both in vivo and in vitro.
And if you see that pattern in a tissue sample, you
can be pretty sure that that person has been exposed to tobacco smoke.
Subsequently, the sequencing of tens of thousands of cancer
genomes and normal genomes has
led to the discovery of
many mutational signatures, and there's now a repertoire of about
80 different mutational signatures that are found naturally
in human tissues, whether they're cancer or
normal tissues.
So in order to use the now available
technology and conceptual framework, Mutagraphs was
structured into six work packages.
First, mutational epidemiology, looking for mutational
signatures in five cancer types in very large numbers of cases
across five continents. Then to develop
computational methods for mutational signature analysis to look for
mutational signatures in rodents exposed to carcinogens,
to look for the signatures in cells exposed to mutagens, to
look more broadly at mutational burdens and signatures
in normal cells, and then to specifically focus on one
type of normal cell, normal white blood cells, to see if
presence detectability of mutational signatures there could be used more
widely in epidemiology.
And so from the
numbers, the multiple observations that were made during the course
of those eight years in Mutagraphs, I've picked out really three
headline discoveries that are thematic
and give a sense of what can be learnt about the causes of
cancer and which continuing work will hopefully
generate more data and more results in the future.
So from that mutational epidemiology part of it, a collection
was made around the world of
eight types of cancer,
which were from 5,000 participants, from which we got cancer and
normal samples and epidemiological metadata.
They came from 30 countries, and all these cancers were whole
genome sequenced. In the map you see in front of you, the blue
represents the parts of the world which were included in this
study.
So the first of the headlines came from studying
esophageal squamous carcinomaAnd now in this map of the
world, the dark blue indicates those parts which have a high
incidence of esophageal squamous carcinoma, and the parts which are
in light blue have a low incidence.
And this is a rather unusual distribution for any cancer type.
You can see there is a high incidence down the east coast
of Africa and across that belt of Central Asia.
That's very unusual. And the differences in cancer
incidence rates between the dark blue and the light blue are huge.
Those are 10 to 20-fold differences.
Exactly what you would expect if there is some
major exposure taking place, which is causing those
differences. You can never exclude that there might be some form of
genetic inherited population difference, but differences
of this size are very unlikely to be due
to those.
So this was our starting point, to look at cancers from those
regions to see what we could find. And there were samples
collected from eight countries, over 500 of them, and
these were whole genome sequenced.
So what did we find? We first of all found we could analyze the data for
sure, and we could find the signatures of a well-known endogenous
mutational process, the APOBEC mutational signatures, which are
due to the APOBEC enzyme family, which are cytosine
deaminases. You find these in many cancer types and also in
some normal tissues. The really unusual thing about esophageal
squamous carcinoma is just how pervasive this
was. Essentially every case had the
APOBEC mutational signatures in it.
Quite unusual, and something that still should continue to be
borne in mind as we think through the implications of the results I'll
tell you about now.
We also could detect
signatures of tobacco and alcohol exposure.
And that's important because it means the system was working in the way that we
wanted it to. We could look at the mutations, we could
extract the signatures, and we could see the patterns of
alcohol exposure and tobacco exposure.
And because we had epidemiological data, we could see that they
correlated with individuals who were smokers and who were drinkers.
However, then when we looked at the data set as a whole,
there were no major differences across these eight countries in
mutation burdens or mutational signatures between them.
There was no new mutational signature there,
nothing that we could look at and say, "Well, yes, that's
likely to be accounting for these huge differences," this huge
exposure which we assumed to be there.
It was a truly resounding negative.
Now, around this time,
the results were beginning to emerge from the rodent studies.
And in those rodent studies, mice had been exposed to about 20
putative environmental human carcinogens, and these
were known or probable or possible carcinogens as defined by
the International Agency for Research on Cancer.
And all of them caused significantly increased tumor incidence in these
mice. So they were all acting as carcinogens.
However, when the tumors from these mice were sequenced,
only three of those carcinogens produced
what you might have expected from a mutagen.
In other words, tumors with a lot of mutations
and tumors with a lot of mutations with distinctive
mutational signatures. That's what you'd have expected
if the tumors had been caused by a mutagen.
But only three of the carcinogens showed
that pattern, the three that are highlighted there.
The remaining 17 did not.
And so that led to the consideration that
perhaps not all carcinogens are mutagens.
So mutagens change mutation loads and they change mutational
signatures. There's that signature there.
But there had been decades of work on a different sort of
carcinogen, which were then called promoters.
And promoters allowed preexisting
mutations to emerge as causing cancer,
but they were not in themselves mutagens.
So promoters change the landscape of normal cell clones with
driver mutations. They change the selective environment.
And that has been given a sort of material reality over the last year
or two because the structure
of mutated clones in normal tissues has become evident.
And that square on the right there is representing
about a centimeter squared of normal esophagus, and each of
those circles there represents a clone of cells.
And if it's colored in, that clone of cells has got a
driver mutation in a cancer gene, a driver
mutation which you would be perfectly happy to find in a cancer
and assume that that mutated gene was implicated in
causing the cancer. But this
is what a normal esophagus looks like.
So it's normal because it looks normal down the microscope, and it's
normal because we all have this going on in us.
And when we get to about the age of 70 or 80,
most of our esophagus is covered by these mutated clones with driver
mutations. So you can see how these promoters might
work, because they could increase the number of those
clones, they could increase the size of the clones, they could change
the mutated genes that are present in those clones, and all of that
could result in a higher risk of the tissue
spawning a cancer. So that's how promoters are thought to
work.Today, some are calling these selectogens,
putting the whole thing within a conceptual framework of somatic
evolution, for which you need mutations, for which mutagens
contribute, and then a changed selective environment
and agents that change that selective environment and encourage
the growth of those clones, some are calling selectogens.
So
probably many of those human carcinogens that were
used in the
mouse studies were
selectogens or promoters, and potentially
whatever is causing that big increase in
esophageal squamous carcinoma in East Africa and in Asia,
possibly that is also a promoter.
So the next cancer type
was renal clear cell cancer, and here the headline is very
different indeed.
You can see that the distribution of renal cancer incidence across the world is
very different from I showed you for esophageal squamous carcinoma, in some
ways, much more familiar. The dark blue areas are in high-income
countries and where cancer is generally higher, and the
light blue areas
in low-income countries.
For renal clear cell cancer, about 1,000 cases were collected
from 11 countries and were sequenced.
So in renal cancer, we could find evidence of
exposures due to exogenous mutagens.
And we'll start with this one. These two signatures,
SBS22A and 22B, you can see they're
composed mainly of these gray mutations, which are T to A mutations.
Very distinctively, we found them clustered
in one geographical area in the southeast of Europe, in Romania,
and Serbia, and Bulgaria.
And there they were present in something like 70% of the cancers.
So most of the cancers had them. Because of
that, because these mutational signatures are so distinctive, we can know
what the agent causing this is, and it is a
set of plant products called aristolochic acids.
The aristolochia genus is quite a widespread genus of
plant,
and many of the species within it produce
mutagens that are shown there, which are known to be
carcinogenic.
So in Southeast Europe, there is
a major exposure to aristolochic acids.
The next observation was this one.
So signature SBS12, which is composed of
those green T to C mutations predominantly, we
found only in Japan. None of the other countries that
we looked at or indeed have looked at subsequently has
this signature in it.
So another very geographically localized
signature, probably due to a geographically localized
exposure, this time of completely unknown
cause. We have no idea what the underlying
agent is.
And then the third one
is this signature, SBS40B. This one is more
ubiquitous, but it does have geographical variation
in incidence, high prevalence in Czech
Republic, low prevalence in Japan.
The amount of this that one finds in a country correlates
with that country's incidence of clear cell renal cancer.
But it is also of unknown cause.
So in renal clear cell cancer, we found multiple
likely exogenous mutagen exposures, including known
carcinogens, the aristolochic acids.
And in Southeast Europe and in Japan, and
certainly for signature 40B, if that is a mutagen, tens of millions of
people are being exposed.
And they're being exposed passively and silently.
They don't know they're being exposed, and they're not
doing anything to be exposed. It's unusual, and it's
a silent exposure.
You can see both known and unknown mutagens, the aristolochic
acids, and then the others that we don't know the cause of.
We also don't know what the consequences are, to be honest.
We know that
some of these are very likely to be exposures, but the consequences, the
cancer risk they confer, that we do not know at the moment.
So the final headline is in colorectal cancer,
where the incidence map is, again, that familiar one,
not so different from renal clear cell cancer, with a high incidence in
high-income countries and low incidence in low-income countries.
Here we sequenced about 1,000 cancers from 11
countries.
And the interest in colorectal cancer has
another dimension to that. In addition to the geographical
variation, there has been temporal variation.
There's been temporal variation over the last 80 years, with some
countries showing a rather extraordinary rise in
colorectal cancer, countries like Japan and Korea, for example.
But over the last 40 years, there has been a very distinctive
rise in early-onset colorectal cancer,
represented in this figure. It's present in many countries.
It's present in many men and women.
And the way to read this chart is that if one is
a
male born in England in 1990,
then one has a fivefold
higher chance of developing early-onset colorectal cancer than if
one had been a male born in England in 1960.
So it's a really steeply rising risk of colorectal
cancer.So
in sequencing those thousand cases of colorectal cancer from around the
world, the major mutational signature of interest is
this one,
SBS88,
which we know is caused by a
mutagen called colibactin.
And
this is a mutagen that's produced by a strain of E.
coli in the microbiome. It's got an extra 50 kb of genome, which
allows it to make colibactin.
SBS88 is found in normal colorectal epithelium.
This is what you'd expect if it is an exposure.
Exposures usually affect normal tissues before they
spawn cancers.
It's interesting because the mutations are imprinted early in life,
and this chimes because those rises in early
onset colorectal cancer, they suggest
that there has been a new exposure during the middle part of the last century, and
that exposure almost certainly is happening in children and
adolescents to give colorectal cancer of that sort of age.
So the fact that this
mutagen is causing mutations very early in life, during the first five
years of life,
has a consistency with that. And it's common.
In looking at the normal colon of about 100
children recently, about 40% of them in the UK who
were born within the last 20 years have got
colibactin
mutational signature in their normal colon.
So it's a common mutagenic exposure.
The interesting observation from the Mutagraphs project was
then when we looked in the colorectal cancers,
there was a difference between the prevalence of the colibactin
signature in cancers of different
ages of diagnosis. So if you look at the green bar on the right,
those are cancers, colorectal cancers, diagnosed at 70 or more, and
10% of them have got the colibactin signature in.
Whereas if we look at cancers diagnosed under the
age of 40 in the purple bar, it's more than a third of them.
So the colibactin mutational signature is being enriched in early onset
colorectal cancer.
So in this tumor type, we find multiple
exogenous mutagen exposures, SBS18 and
colibactin, but actually a number of others too that I won't talk about.
These are quite common. Colibactin and SBS8 is probably the most
common, but the others are also common.
They show substantial geographic variation.
So in some parts of the world, the other mutational signatures, which
are also quite likely to be due to mutagen exposures from the
microbiome, are the most common.
Most of them are unknown cause, but as I've just said, probably
many of them are also derived from the microbiome as
colibactin is.
And for many of them, they follow that same pattern that the mutations
are imprinted early in life.
So SBS88 is enriched in early onset colorectal cancer,
so that has spawned the hypothesis that over the last 100
years, there has been an increase in prevalence of colibactin-producing
microbes in many countries.
And that that increase
and the additional mutational burden it confers in the
normal colons of children is causing the increase in early
onset colorectal cancer that's been observed over the last 40 years.
So this hypothesis is being now investigated, and
you will hear more about it if you attend tomorrow's plenary, to which
Ludmil Alexandrov will talk more about this work.
So in summary, for the whole of Mutagraphs,
some human carcinogens may
be promoters or selectogens, and possibly it's better to talk about this
that all carcinogens have some mutagenic
activity, and all of them have some selectogenic activity, and it's the
balance between those that causes how well they cause
cancer.
That there are population scale silent mutagen exposures
which exist. We weren't aware of these previously, and the
sequencing and the mutational signatures allows them to be identified.
And that microbiome-derived mutagens may increase colorectal cancer
risk and cause the current rise in early onset colorectal
cancer.
And that mutational epidemiology generally offers an alternative
strategy for investigating the causes of cancer.
There are literally hundreds of people, as you can imagine, with all those
collections over in all those countries that need to be thanked for doing
this work. Some of the people who worked on the genomics are
shown here, and I'd like to thank Cancer Grand Challenges,
first of all, for the conception of the Grand Challenge, second of all, for putting
the challenge to work on mutational signatures, and third of all, for
the really considerate and thoughtful way that they helped us manage
Mutagraphs through its eight years of existence. Thank you very much.
Thank you, Mike.
Next we have Alan Balmain.
Alan was originally a chemist, studied chemistry at the University of
Glasgow and carried out his post-doctoral work in France and then
Germany.
He has been professor at UCSF for
some time now. 15 years, maybe longer.
And leads a group that uses systemic or systems genetics, I should say,
approaches to understand cancer complexity.
He's been a leading light in the field of selectogens or promoters.
He's been working on the Benham Bloom model for much of his
career.
And his recent work is really beginning to describe very nicely at a molecular
level-How those original observations by Bern Bloom in
1947 pan out in the skin papilloma
model in mice. He's co-team lead of the
Cancer Grand Challenge team PROMINENT, which seeks to understand how
latent mutated cells in normal tissues become activated by
promoters, as you heard from Mike earlier, to cause cancer.
He's also a Fellow of the Royal Society since 2015.
In the US, he was elected fellow of the AACR Academy, fellow of the
American Association for the Advancement of Science.
He's received numerous awards, including the
2024 Princess Takamatsu Foundation Award Lectureship.
It's a great pleasure to introduce you, Alan.
We're looking forward to hearing the latest update.
Let me see if this... Ah, okay.
Well, thank you, Charlie, for the introduction.
And also thanks to Mike, in the first place many years
ago, for asking me to be involved in the Mutagrass project, which you've
just heard about.
So I'm representing the team PROMINENT, and the acronym stands
for Studies of Promotion to Inform Prevention.
So as Paul Brennan came up with that title, I think it fits
rather well.
I first want to thank the Cancer Grand Challenges team
for everything they've done
to set up this whole program, which has really been, for me,
transformative, liberating in many ways.
But also the CRUK, who funded our work many
years ago, and the NCI, who funded the other half of the work for many
years. So, this is a long connection with both of those
funding bodies over many decades, more decades than I care to remember.
The
topic that PROMINENT is working on is how does the
environment influence cancer, and what can we do about it?
When you look in the newspapers or you open up
your iPhone these days, there's always something new about this
compound or that chemical or this thing in the environment
that's causing cancer. You heard from Mike about
the increasing incidence of early onset colon cancer.
We don't know what those causes are.
And this slide has a whole list of possible risk factors
from the environment,
lifestyle factors,
endogenous processes. Aging is a very important
association with cancer.
The problem is that we don't know which of these really are the main causes, which
are the main drivers of the whole process of
mutation and clonal selection. So we need to study these in
great detail and find ways to monitor them, to test them,
to quantify their roles, and be much more
quantitative in our assessments of what these risk factors actually are.
Superimposed on all of this, of course, is genetic background.
We're all unique individuals with our own
set of polymorphisms that we've inherited, and these genetic
backgrounds, they affect all of the things that you see on this slide.
The propensity for
responding to a carcinogen can depend on metabolism.
It can depend on many things, transport,
all of which can be influenced by our own polymorphism.
So this is something hovering in the background that we really,
within PROMINENT, we're not
looking at this in great detail, but it's a major feature that we
need to take into consideration in the future.
So the role of the environment in cancer, of course, goes back hundreds of years.
This is something that many of you, I'm sure, have seen.
Percival Pott in the 18th century found that chimney
sweeps had a high incidence of scrotal cancer.
A hundred and fifty years or so later, Yamagiwa
and Ichikawa, they did the causal, the Koch's postulate type
experiment. They took the coal tar, and they treated
rabbits on the ears with coal tar repeatedly.
Those rabbits got cancer. So that was the first causal link
between exposure to anything, basically, and increasing
cancer risk.
That ear that got the cancer is still in the museum in Tokyo.
You can visit it and see it if you feel so inclined.
Thirty years after those experiments, in the 1940s,
the group that Charlie mentioned in his introduction, Bern Bloom
and Shubik, they did the first studies on trying to
separate environmental carcinogenesis into different stages.
And they used the coal tar that also gave the rabbit
carcinoma.
But what they showed was that coal tar in low doses as
a single treatment did nothing. If you treat the mice with coal tar
and wait for a whole year, they got no tumors.
Similarly, if you treated them with an agent that caused inflammation and
irritation on the skin, also the mice did not get any
tumors. But in the third line here down, if you
did the coal tar first and then chronic exposure to
inflammation, then lots of tumors came up.
The mice got benign tumors literally in a few weeks, and they developed
malignant tumors in a couple of months, a few months, and that killed them.
The order was important. If you do all that chronic inflammation
first and then the coal tar, you don't get the tumors.
It has to be coal tar first, followed by mutations.
This bottom line here
is a very important experiment that Bern Bloom and Shubik did,
which really introduced, I think, another dimension to the whole discussion
about mutations versusNo, I shouldn't say versus mutations,
in addition to inflammation and how these work together.
What they showed was that the promotion step, in other words, the inflammation,
was actually the rate-limiting step.
You could do a single treatment with the coal tar and then wait
until the mouse is almost dead,
18 months, and then begin the promoter treatment, the inflammation
treatment, and the tumors came up within a few weeks.
So those, whatever was happening by with coal tar, that was permanent.
And those cells sit there for the life of the mice, don't do anything, but when
they're exposed to
a neurotoxin for just a short time, then they begin to expand.
So
this now, I'm going to run through this quickly because I don't want to go
too much,
or at all over my time.
So going from the early stuff from Pot,
there's a huge amount of work done over the decades by many
different groups. Kennaway found the important
constituents in the coal tar.
The Millers showed that these constituents, these chemicals, they require
metabolic activation. They just don't get into cells and do stuff.
They need to be metabolically activated.
Charlie Heidelberg has showed that they can form or do form direct
adducts with the DNA. They stick onto the DNA, and that's what causes
the ultimate mutations.
We got into this in the early '80s by taking some of these mutagens
and showing that they cause specific kinds of mutations in animal models.
And that, of course, was taken to another dimension in the work that you've just
heard about from Mike, in the early '20s.
How they developed this concept of mutational signatures,
which has really transformed our understanding of how
these carcinogens are distributed throughout the world and contribute to
many thousands of cancer types.
We also need to think about promotion.
The inflammation connection to cancer, of course, goes
back again, Virchow back in
1855, and many other people since then.
The slide space isn't big enough to acknowledge everything.
The Bernblum and Shubik experiment, we've already many mentioned, but
it has to be remembered that in the '50s and '60s,
these promotion experiments, inflammation and promotion, were carried out with
what we now know are very potent mutagens: tobacco, cigarette
smoke, and air pollution.
They have both promoting activity as well as mutagenic activity.
And I think this is an important
component that we have to think about, is these are
interacting all the time in complex ways that we really don't
understand.
It's not just like a mouse experiment where you have a constant dose.
There's variable dose levels, various combinations are involved
in exposures in human populations.
Hecker was the guy I did my postdoc with.
He found TPA, which is the quintessential tumor promoter.
Sugimura extended this whole field by showing that you can have
completely different types of promoters that have different mechanisms of action.
The promotion work
was in its heyday in the '70s, '80s, and '90s.
This is a group in Heidelberg I worked with.
In the US, there were many groups working on mechanisms of promotion.
But all of that kind of tailed off in the '80s when
mutations came along. We all shifted to look at mutations,
including my own lab. We switched and did a lot of work then on
mutations. But now what I was told for this is I have to talk
about how mutations and inflammation conspire together.
So that was the title I was given for the talk.
So we went back a few years ago and repeated the original Bernblum
experiment to see, are they right?
Were they right that the initiation event was
permanent? First of all, in the 1980s, we had actually
identified the initiation event for this model.
It's a specific mutation, an A-to-T mutation
in codon 61 of Ras,
and that's because the DMBA binds to adenosines, and it causes an
A-to-T mutation. So that gives us a mutational signature.
At that point, this was a single nucleotide signature.
This has now, of course, been extended to trinucleotide and pentanucleotide
signatures. But we could look for that mutational signature in
tumors that were induced by this carcinogen, and that's what you see on the
bottom part of this slide.
The Y-axis here are mutation numbers in
individual carcinomas from these mice, all skin tumors.
And some of them, as you can see, have 30,000 mutations,
up to 50,000 mutations. The purple is the
DMBA signature. So that means that these bars, since
initiation is on one day, all of the mutations are caused on that
one day or within a week of that first
exposure. So it's a snapshot in time of
how many mutations that single dose of
DMBA can actually cause.
And what it says is that on the right, where it says standard, that's the
classic model. You take young mice, you treat them once with DMBA,
stimulate them with inflammatory agents, TPA in this case,
get the tumors, and sequence them.
And there's a lot of variability in the number of DMBA-induced
mutations. But they all have exactly the same initiating mutations,
which is that HRAS thing I showed earlier.
So that is the one common factor. All the other mutations
are optional.
When we did the Bernblum experiment with the delay, which is on the left
here,
there was no difference in the numbers or the types of mutations compared to the
standard model, so they were right.
This tumor hereThat has the almost 50,000 mutations.
That was sitting in a mouse skin for almost a year and didn't do anything,
but then it gave tumors a few weeks after we started the
promotion experiment. So they were absolutely spot on.
They did speculate at that time that this was a mutational event.
Of course, we didn't know what the structure of DNA was then, so I don't know
how they managed to come to that conclusion.
But they said this was a mutational event, and they were
absolutely correct in assuming that.
This is the experiment you already saw from Mike,
showing that mutations are an
important feature of many chemicals that are in the
environment. But what this slide shows, and Mike
emphasized, is that the vast majority of
chemicals that the National Toxicology Program and
IARC have classified as being potential carcinogens,
they are not mutagenic as far as we can tell.
Only two or three out of the 20 that were
assessed showed any mutational signatures.
All of the others looked exactly like spontaneous
tumors, the same numbers of mutations,
the same types of mutations.
So,
this takes me on to the work in Prominent, the more recent work, a
scientific vignette, just to finish off.
So what we've been trying to do within Prominent is
go back to the beginnings and look at where the
initiating mutations are, which cells are they in, how many are there,
and how do they respond to promoters? Do different promoters do different things?
Do they have a common mechanism of action?
So here you have a diagram. This is
taken from a recent review. Nuria
Lopez-Bigas, who I think is here.
We conspired together, the Prominent team, and wrote this review on promotion.
So anything that you miss in the next few slides, you'll find in
that review.
So the idea is that we can identify single mutated
cells, as shown by these colored
hexagons in an epithelial tissue.
When we treat with TPA, some of those specific mutant cells will
clonally expand, and if the purple cells clonally expand
enough, then they will give us a tumor.
There are, however, other sources of mutations in all of our
normal tissues,
and they could be carcinogen induced or they could be
spontaneous.
And if they are spontaneous, then maybe they respond.
Maybe the red clones respond to TPA, and they'll give us a red
tumor. If the tissue is exposed to a different
type of promoter, like wounding or PFAS,
other chemicals that are very good candidate promoters,
then maybe they will select a different clone.
And I think that's a theme that's emerging from many of the studies we're now
doing, is that these selective constraints are very specific.
There's a zoo of mutations and mutant clones in our tissues, all of our
normal tissues, and they're responding in very different ways to what we eat, what
we drink, what we're exposed to.
The workhorse tool for analyzing these
mutations, which are very rare mutations in normal tissues, was
developed by Jesse Salk and his company, TwinStrand, which
unfortunately has now, I think, gone out of business.
But it's an amazingly efficient way to look at really,
really rare mutations in single cells and
in tissues. So we've been using this extensively with a lot of
help from Nuria's team,
to develop our own process now for going through this, since the
company has gone out of business. So I just want to quickly take you through what
we've been seeing with this very deep sequencing approach, where you're hunting
for rare mutant cells in these normal
tissues. So this box up at the top here, these
pink boxes, each box represents one mouse.
And this is looking for mutations in RAS genes, NRAS,
KRAS, and HRAS, those three very famous RAS genes.
And the top panel,
these are controls. These are young mice.
There are 10 mice there. Five of them have mutations, five of
them do not have mutations. And that's the kind of statistics we see.
We take the DNA, we do deep sequencing.
Sometimes we find some of these mutant cells.
But what you can see is that
within those three RAS genes,
there's... This pointer I don't think is working here, actually.
No, it's not. Anyway.
Yeah. Within these three RAS genes,
several of the boxes have a KRAS G12D mutation, which is
one of the most common mutations found in human cancers.
Several others have a KRAS G13R mutation.
These are very common mutations for some unknown
reason in normal mouse tissues. Both of those mutations come up
repeatedly.
And when we add the DMBA on the middle set of panels
there, then you can begin to see
the codon 61 mutations that all come.
There's a whole bunch of different codon 61 mutations that you can now see
a week after that single treatment with the DMBA.
So these are the classic initiating mutations.
We see codon 61 in HRAS, KRAS, and
NRAS. But then when we treat those with the promoter TPA,
the biggest pink circles are HRAS Q61L.
So those are the mutations that we find in the actual tumors from this model.
The other mutations are there. They're all very
strong, well-characterized RAS mutations, but they do not respond
to this particular promoter very well.
The one that comes through is the HRAS Q61L.
But just a quick word about these spontaneous mutations, because I think it's
relevant also to some of the work that Mike talked about.
We all have spontaneous mutations.
We tend to think of them as being random.New mistakes in
DNA repair during DNA replication.
These two I mentioned, G12D and G13R, are very common.
They do respond to TPA. You see these big pink circles for
G12. These are all independent mice, and that shows all of
the mutations in those mice, not just those ones.
But when you look over time, what we find is that on the
right panel there, if you look at the KRAS G12D, that's TPA
alone. The blue intensity shows those mutations are increasing with TPA.
But then the next two squares are white.
That means they've disappeared. So if you wait for another four weeks, they've
gone.
So basically what we find is that these spontaneous
mutations do respond initially to the promoter, but then they crash
out and they disappear. And we don't know why they disappear or how they disappear,
but they do. And if you then, on the right-hand panel, is a
DMBA-initiated set of mutations in all three
RAS genes. You can see the strongest blue line is opposite HRAS
Q61L. That's the one that goes up and keeps going up and gives you
the tumor. But you can also see that the KRAS G13R on the
right-hand panel is this intense blue signal there, too.
So that is responding very well, even after DMBA to
promotion. But again, it crashes out, and it never gives you a tumor
under those circumstances. What we have, however, found
is that, so these green bars here, this is the KRAS
G13R, which has turned out to be very fascinating.
It goes up in response to short-term TPA
in non-initiated mice and also in initiated mice.
It goes up, but in both cases, if you keep going, it disappears.
So those mutant cells do not ever give us any tumors in wild-type
mice.
But if we generate HRAS knockout mice,
then we get lots of tumors with those two specific mutations.
So those are spontaneous mutations, which are revealed when you knock out
the competing HRAS gene. And this whole field of
competition
goes back to Hinis Murata in Drosophila many years
ago, showing how different clones of cells compete with each other
for space, for nutrients, for survival
in these tissues.
So this is an experiment with the HRAS knockout mice.
And what you can see is the green bar shows these are HRAS knockout
mice treated chronically with TPA.
And across the bottom on the right, those mice get very, very
few tumors compared to the wild-type mice.
But the tumors they do get have that bright green signal.
Those are KRAS G13R mutations. That's not a
mutation that's caused by DMBA. It doesn't have the
signature. It's spontaneous. But nevertheless, it's selected
by this whole process.
So this, I think, helps us to understand some of the data
that have been very confusing, at least to us, over the years.
On the left, there are several papers from the group of Valentina
Greco,
who has followed on this
idea started by Murata about cell-cell competition.
And she has looked at competition between different clones in normal
tissue. And she has shown very elegantly that if
you induce mutations genetically
in KRAS or HRAS, so you have a lot of mutations driven
genetically by tissue-specific promoters,
you should get loads of cancers, but you don't.
And they've shown that the normal cells outcompete
the RAS mutant cells in these tissues.
I never understood it because the paper on the right is the one that I
showed you earlier, which clearly shows that the RAS mutations sit there for a
year. They're definitely not outcompeted by the normal cells.
It turns out these are two different categories of mutations and probably
in two different cell types. We don't fully understand this yet.
So this whole idea about clonal competition is
going on in all of us all the time, but I think there
is a huge amount that we still have to understand.
We're taking a number of approaches within Prominent to look at ways
to monitor these processes and
understand these processes and ultimately to try to prevent
these processes. I'm sure I've gone over time, so I'm going to stop here.
These are the people who've been doing all of this work over the
years. On the left is the larger Prominent team.
Paul Brennan is over on the left here.
Nuria is in the middle somewhere. Yes, there she is there.
She's about 10th from the right. I should have put an arrow on
there. Nuria and Paul are the co-leaders of the
team. Nuria has a beautiful paper which has just come out, I think, in
Nature,
using all of these same technologies but to look at human bladder cancer
and has identified TERT promoter mutations
that are directly linked to cigarette smoking, but this is in bladder.
So very, very interesting work. I'd recommend that you go and read that paper.
The others on the right, this is the core group at UCSF.
Eve Kandiba has done much of the clonal selection work,
helped by
Andrea Cortabi and many of the others here.
And I'd like to thank again the Cancer Research team
for all of their support over the years. Thank you.
Thank you, Alan.
Again, we'll have questions right at the end. So next we have Karen Kochowski.
Karen is a professor at Brigham and Women's Hospital, Harvard Medical School.
Her research focuses on deconstructing the pathogenesis of
RAS-related signaling pathways in cancer.
She's been a central member of the Specify Cancer team that seeks to
understand why specific oncogenic drivers occur
in some tissues, some tumor types, but not others.
A really central question to understanding signal transduction across organ
sites and their role in cancer initiation and
maintenance.So she's been studying the intersection between oncogenic and
epigenetic signals in cancer and investigating how convergent
points represent new and unique nodes of
vulnerability. She's published some really elegant work showing how
combinations of inhibitors such as EZH2,
AKT inhibitors, can rewire triple-negative breast cancer cells
and differentiate them into sort of more luminal progenitors that become
sensitive to both treatments. I'm sure she'll discuss similar such work
today, funded from Specify Cancer,
and it's been really a phenomenally successful grand challenge
in collaboration with Steve Elledge.
She's received the Translational Science Award of the Children's
Tumor Foundation, the Innovative Research Idea Prize,
and amongst others, the National Neurofibromatosis Foundation
Prize, and several other accolades I haven't got time to say today.
Karen, welcome. Thank you very much.
Great. Thank you very much. I would just like to thank the
organizers of this particular session for inviting me to present our work today.
But more importantly, I'd really like to thank the Cancer Research UK and the Mark
Foundation for funding our Specify Cancer Grand Challenge team.
And as you've heard from others, this has really been a transformative opportunity.
So, so far we've heard about how known and unknown carcinogens
and clonal expansion function in cancer promotion,
and I will now talk about how epigenetic events contribute to these
processes, and in particular, how epigenetic
defects cooperate with more classical
oncogenes to drive very tumor-specific and
tissue-specific biology. And moreover, how this
results in the development of therapeutic vulnerabilities that can be
readily targeted.
So by way of background, I was a PI on the Specify Cancer team
led by Steve Elledge, and our broad goal was to investigate
why specific oncogenes and tumor suppressors are so tumor-specific,
and second, to use this insight, as well as unbiased approaches,
to identify novel tissue-specific therapeutic vulnerabilities.
Our team focused on the RAS pathway,
the WNT pathway, the PRC2 complex, and also
employed broader genetic and computational
approaches to create tissue-specific maps of unique
drivers and therapeutic vulnerabilities.
Christian Helene and I specifically worked on understanding how
defects in this epigenetic complex, the PRC2 complex,
contributes to tumor development and progression, and more
broadly, how epigenetic alterations both permit and
reinforce the tissue-specific activity of these and other
oncogenic pathways.
And so because I was asked to speak about epigenetics, I
will limit my discussion today on that.
So if you think about it, epigenetic regulators are truly the guardians of tissue
specificity and perhaps oncogenesis in general.
Because while tumors contain alterations in many oncogenic drivers that
control cell signaling, for example, the ultimate
transcriptional output of any upstream oncogenic event
is largely dependent on the epigenetic state of a tissue, which can drive
either the amplification or the repression of specific transcriptional
responses. And so we thought that if we wanted to really understand the
tissue specificity of the PRC2 complex, we need to study
it in conjunction
with tissue-specific oncogenic drivers.
So in doing so, we decided to focus on breast cancer,
where PI3-kinase pathway mutations are highly enriched compared to
other tumor types. And so for example, 40% of
hormone receptor-positive luminal tumors harbor mutations in
PIK3CA.
And as such, PI3-kinase alpha-selective inhibitors and AKT
inhibitors have each been approved for the treatment of advanced hormone
receptor-positive disease.
However, these agents are not effect in triple-negative breast cancer, at least
when combined with chemotherapy.
But we wondered if perhaps these tumors might not be responding, not
because the PI3-kinase pathway isn't important, but because they're in a
less differentiated, more basal-like state as compared to these
ER-positive tumors.
And if so, perhaps we might be able to sensitize these tumors to AKT
inhibitors if we're able to shift them somehow to this more
luminal-like state,
which is what really led us to the PRC2 complex.
So the PRC2 complex, it drives histone H2K27
methylation, and through its catalytic component, EZH2,
silences specific genes, often those associated with differentiation.
And in fact, EZH2 is known to be broadly involved in stem cell maintenance.
Moreover, EZH2 and the PRC2 complex in general does play an
oncogenic role in a specific subset of cancers.
Gain-of-function mutations do occur in melanoma and lymphoma, for
example, but it is more frequently overexpressed in a small
subset of solid tumors, including breast, colon, and prostate.
In triple-negative breast cancer, it's overexpressed in about 80% to 90%
of the cases. As you can see here,
it has also been shown to play a functional role in breast cancer development and
metastasis.So fortunately, several
EZH2 inhibitors have been developed, as well as agents that target
EED, another obligate component of this
complex.
And so we wanted to determine whether EZH2 inhibitors might
sensitize TNBCs to AKT inhibitors by promoting some
kind of shift in their differentiation state.
To investigate this, we pre-treated a panel of TNBC cell lines with the
EZH2 inhibitor for several days to allow for turnover of
H3K27 methylation, and then added on the AKT inhibitor,
and found that when these agents are combined, they exert a potent cytotoxic
response at about 60% of the models that we evaluated,
as depicted by these red bars here.
And this, importantly, was not observed in response to either agent
alone.
These agents trigger cell death, but again, only when combined.
As you can see from this Incucyte, a live cell imaging analysis of
apoptosis,
they kill in a dose-dependent fashion, and they're highly synergistic.
Moreover, they cooperate to cause potent tumor regression in
vivo in very aggressive xenografts and genetically engineered
mouse models, as well as several PDX
tumors. And this type of response is highly unusual in
triple-negative breast cancer.
But what is the mechanism of action?
So to investigate this, we performed RNA-seq and immediately noticed that
EZH2 and AKT inhibitors together increase the expression of
normal mature luminal markers in these cells
and concomitantly suppress mammary stem cell markers.
And what was surprising to us was that this shift in cell state was
truly cooperative, which can be best visualized by these heat maps.
You can see that you need both EZH2 and AKT inhibitors to induce
the mature luminal signature, and you need both agents
to most potently suppress the basal and stem cell
signatures.
You can also really visualize this quite rapidly in patient-derived
tumors in vivo using cyclic immunofluorescence.
As you can see, tumors start out broadly expressing basal markers.
So for example, cytokeratin 14 is shown here in green.
But after just one day of treatment with the combination, tumors completely
adopt this more luminal-like state, as depicted by the complete shift from
green to purple, which marks the luminal
protein cytokeratin 8, with the exception of this outer
rim, which I'll be getting back to in a second.
At the same time, and these are the same tumors, you see a potent induction of
apoptosis in luminal cells, as depicted by the
yellow, which marks cleaved PARP.
After a few days, you start seeing clearing
of these cells, and after about a month, it looks like these hollowed-out
tumors have collapsed onto themselves like a paper bag, and there are only an
occasional remnant tumor knobs, which are
largely quiescent.
So if we overlay this onto a very simplified cartoon of mammary
gland development, we find that EZH2 and AKT inhibitors
cooperatively drive TNBCs to a more mature, luminal-like state.
And so we wondered whether this shift in differentiation state was actually
required for the therapeutic response.
We therefore looked at GATA3, which is the master developmental transcription
factor that drives luminal differentiation in the normal mammary
gland,
and interestingly found that both EZH2 and AKT inhibitors
cooperatively induce GATA3 mRNA and protein
levels.
But more importantly, when we knock it out,
we inhibit the therapeutic response.
Cells no longer die in vitro, and you can see tumors no longer
shrink in vivo.
But two questions remain.
First, how can we predict responses or can we predict responses?
And second, how does tumor cells actually die?
Now, because EZH2 and PI3 kinase pathway alterations occur in the
majority of TNBCs, we don't think they're very useful biomarkers.
However, principal component analysis of attack seq data can
readily distinguish sensitive cells in blue and resistant
cells in red. And so there is something inherently different
about the state of these cells even before treatment.
Moreover, we found that GATA3 could not be induced, so we
couldn't trigger the cell state change by EZH2 and AKT
inhibitors in these resistant lines.
We then performed an unbiased gene expression analysis in untreated
cells and found that the most differentially enriched signatures in
the resistant tumors were
mesenchymal signatures, whereas in the sensitive tumors, they were more
enriched for these basal-like genes.
So in other words, we believe or we hypothesize that
resistant cells cannot differentiate and therefore cannot die because
they're too undifferentiated or too mesenchymal.
Unfortunately, however, published mesenchymal and basal
signatures were not sufficient
to completely predict sensitivity or resistance.
And so we collaborated with Simon Knott and used a machine and learning approach
to identify a predictive signature.
This signature needs to be evaluated prospectively in the clinic, but we do hope
that it ultimately could be used in the way that the HRD signature
is currently being used to select patients for PARP inhibitor trials.
But how do they actually die?
To investigate this, again, we looked at our RNA-seq data and saw that apoptosis
signatures were upregulated. In fact, we found that this
one gene, BMF, was the most highly upregulated gene within this signature.
And as you can see,
both EZH2 and AKT inhibitors cooperatively induce its
expression.More
importantly, when you knock out BMF in vitro and again in vivo, you
inhibit cell death of the therapeutic response in vitro, and you
inhibit tumor regression in vivo.
So it is essential for this complete therapeutic response.
Now, when we obtained this result, we considered the normal role that BMF
plays in the mammary gland and noted that it drives cell death during the
process of involution
at the cessation of lactation. And so we wondered if these
agents were triggering a similar process in tumor cells.
And indeed, we found that these agents induce a transcriptional response that's
very reminiscent of that, that occurs during the process of involution,
and again, required both EZH2 and AKT
inhibitors.
We then asked, are EZH2 and AKT inhibitors activating the same
classical upstream signals that drive involution?
Specifically during the process of involution, BMF is activated by a
JAK1-STAT3 program, and in fact, we found that this
is the case.
JAK1 and STAT3 are cooperatively activated.
They're required for BMF expression, and if you ablate either one of them,
you abolish the therapeutic response.
So to summarize this part of our work in breast cancer, we found that
EZH2 and AKT inhibitors kill triple-negative breast cancers
by cooperatively promoting differentiation
to a more luminal-like state, which involves the cooperative induction of
GATA3.
Through a mechanism I don't really have time to talk about today, but involves the
de-repression of the GATA3 enhancer, and then subsequent
binding and transcriptional activation by FOXO1, explaining
the cooperativity of both the chromatin events and oncogene events
in this process.
These agents then hijack involution signals, specifically JAK1,
STAT3, and BMF, to trigger cell death.
I didn't have time to go through the data, but this is mediated
by STING and IL-6.
By contrast, cells that are resistant or models that are resistant, you don't see
differentiation, and you don't see this induction of BMF
or apoptosis. So when thinking about this in
the context of tumor development,
what this means is that EZH2 and AKT actually converge
to reinforce these two essential signals, ensuring that
both differentiation and apoptotic responses are suppressed in these tumors,
which is why you need both agents to initiate a therapeutic response.
However, this turns out to be a much broader therapeutic paradigm.
So specifically, we found that various oncogenic inhibitors
cooperate with EZH2 inhibitors in other tumor types.
So for example, EZH2 inhibitors also kill K-RAS mutant colorectal
cancers when combined with RAS pathway inhibitors.
They kill PTEN mutant castration-resistant prostate cancer when combined with
either AKT or mTORC1 inhibitors, and they kill
HER2-positive breast cancers, in particular, the resistant tumors,
when combined with these HER2 kinase inhibitors.
So these observations are very important on their own, and we're
actively using them to try to develop clinical trials for some of these and other
refractory tumor types. However, we've also been able to
generate both common and tissue-specific mechanistic themes by
comparing and contrasting findings in these different tissues.
For example, I just told you that EZH2 and AKT inhibitors kill
TNBCs by driving differentiation and triggering an
involution-like response, anyway, mediated by BMF.
This mechanism is thematically similar to what we see in colorectal
cancer. Specifically, EZH2 and RAS pathway inhibitors
trigger the induction of TLE4 and WNT and other WNT pathway
suppressors, and this results in the potent suppression of WNT signaling, which
in the colon drives differentiation and then cell death.
Moreover, like breast tissue, BMF has also been proposed to play a role
in normal intestinal homeostasis.
Specifically, it's exclusively induced in differentiated cells
as they migrate up the crypt
to promote normal intestinal cell turnover.
So again, these agents appear to be hijacking normal developmental
processes.
Now, this is similar but not exactly what is occurring
in prostate and HER2-positive breast
cancers.
So in prostate cancer, these agents trigger a catastrophic
reprogramming of metabolism, which shuts off both glycolysis and
oxidative phosphorylation through effects on MYC and HIF1A.
And we believe that these effects on metabolism are related to the unique
metabolic plasticity that's required during the development and progression of
prostate cancer,
which requires metabolic rewiring to shut off citrate
secretion into prostatic fluid and begin to use it as
oxidative phosphorylation early in tumor development, followed by a second
switch to aerobic glycolysis as tumors become castration-resistant.
So metabolic plasticity is especially critical in this tissue.
And finally, in HER2-positive breast cancers, we see a different type of
reprogramming that involves YAP, which I don't have time to discuss.
But I would just like to highlight that in every case, there is some kind of shift
in cell state, which is related to the unique biology of that tissue.
In all cases, cell death is mediated in part by BMF,
which appears to be a very important repressed PRC2
target.
So I just wanted to end with some broader conceptual
conclusions.
So I've told you today that tissue specificity in cancer arises
from cooperative interactions between epigenetic regulators and
oncogenic signaling pathways,
and that epigenetic events, at least in part, reinforce the most
important tissue-specific oncogenic signals in a given
tissue.Because of this, therapeutic
responses require the combined suppression of epigenetic and oncogenic pathways.
And finally, we found that some drug combinations can
kill tumors by hijacking normal tissue-specific pathways involved in
homeostasis.
But I would like to end up by highlighting the fact that the majority of data
that I showed you today really challenged the notion that drug
combinations must be comprised of agents that exhibit single agent activity in
a given tissue. And if we restrict our clinical trials in this way,
we are likely to miss effective combinations that work
cooperatively driving biological changes.
And with that, I'd just like to thank the people that did the work.
Everyone in blue worked on breast cancer, everyone in green worked on prostate
cancer, and everyone in red worked on colon cancer.
And I'd like to thank my Specify Cancer Grand Challenge team, as
well as CRUK and the Mark Foundation for supporting this work. Thank you.
Thank you, Karen.
And last but not least, Eileen White, who is leading CanCan,
the Cachexia Consortium Grand Challenge that I told you about earlier.
Eileen is deputy director of the Rutgers Cancer Institute, and is associate
director of the Ludwig Princeton branch at Princeton University.
As I said, she's PI for the team CanCan for the CGC, addressing
mechanisms that are causing cancer cachexia.
She's well-known for her work establishing the DNA tumor virus and an
oncogene it encodes, induces, or rather inhibits, I should say,
programmed cell death,
and is a homologue of the human BCL2 oncogene.
Her honors include election to the US National Academy of Sciences and the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences. She's also an elected fellow of the American
Association for the Advancement of Science and the American Academy of
Microbiology, and of course, the AACR Academy. Welcome, Eileen.
Thank you.
Well, it's my pleasure to be here and represent
Team CanCan and my two co-leads,
Tobias Janowitz and Marcos Goncalves, who
have led cancer cachexia sessions earlier in the meeting.
So cancer cachexia is a common wasting syndrome.
You're probably all familiar with it.
Cancer patients will experience a loss of
food intake or anorexia, sickness, weakness,
malaise, apathy, depression,
and
ultimately, this wasting syndrome leads to the death
of most patients with advanced cancer.
And so what we wanted to understand is
what is this wasting syndrome, and can
we stop it? And if we do stop it, the
expectation would be an improvement in
therapeutic outcome, but also an improvement in the quality of
life for cancer patients and their families.
So cancer cachexia is a poster
child for a systemic effect of cancer.
There are the well-known wasting of fat
and atrophy of muscle.
These
phenotypes of cancer cachexia received a lot of attention.
But I think where CanCan wanted to focus
was on identification of the tumor factors that cause these
systemic alterations that collectively lead to this
wasting syndrome.
So some of the tumor factors are known, and
they include IL6, LIP, GDF15, CCL2, and
so on. While many are unknown, and what they do is not
entirely clear.
But cancer cachexia is associated with systemic inflammation.
This includes
chemokines and cytokines and hormones.
Also an abnormal immune response.
There's neutrophilia that's common in cachexia.
There's prominent changes in liver metabolism and
liver function, including activation of the acute phase
response and inflammation.
These are inappropriate liver functions for someone that
has lost their appetite and is not eating.
There are systemic metabolic alterations.
One of the things that CanCan has discovered is that
a prominent metabolic feature of cancer cachexia is
sustained and high glucose turnover flux.
And again, this is an abnormal response to nutrient limitation.
But many of the effects that we are seeing in cancer
cachexia are the tumor modifying the function of the brain.
And this, I think, is very fascinating in that
a lot of the wasting is caused by
actually the patients lose their appetite.
So understanding how the various mechanisms by
which that occurs is very important.
Patients with cancer cachexia get depressed.
They lose motivation, so there's no reward for
positive experiences. They have apathy.
They have reduced physical activity.
I'm sure all of the clinicians in the audience will
be very familiar with these phenotypes.
So these are the types of things that we have focused on, and
I'll try to give you a few examples of what we
found in our course with
Team CanCan. And I'll start with brain signaling
drivers of cancer cachexia. So the O'Reilly and Co.
Labs are leaders
in the field of understanding the hormone
GDF15, which acts in the brain through its receptor,
GFRA1. And what they did was identify a novel
neuronal circuit that results in the production of glucocorticoids,
and that can lead to muscle wasting.And the
Janowitz lab
made some important discoveries, including
that the cachectic factor IL-6 that's produced by the
tumor acts in the brain to induce a novel
neuronal circuit that limits the production
of dopamine, and that limitation in dopamine
leads to apathy, another common phenotype
of cancer cachexia.
The next question we wanted to ask is: Is there a
dietary remedy for this wasting syndrome?
And this is an important question because normally if you take a cachectic
patient and try to maintain their calorie intake,
it doesn't really help.
So one of the things that we found, and I'll tell you about it in a
moment, is if you put
mice on a high-fat
diet, so a high-calorie
diet, it actually worsens cancer cachexia.
And the Papagiannopoulos lab worked out the mechanism
is that in the context of a high-fat diet, this causes
production of prostaglandin E2 in the
tumor, and that signals through the vagus
nerve to induce
exacerbated cancer cachexia in mice.
And they also
discovered various interventions to interfere with
this function of prostaglandin E2
produced by high-fat diet and
from the tumor.
The next we wanted to address the metabolic drivers of cancer
cachexia.
We have developed various genetically engineered mouse models of
cachexia. Here is an example from what we
found in mouse models of pancreas cancer.
The
mice lose weight. They lose lean mass and fat mass.
There's a genetic model and an orthotopic model.
The results are the same. And if we characterize
the global metabolism of these animals, you see that
in the orange, that the mice with pancreas cancer
lose their appetite and reduce their food intake, and they reduce their
locomotion, and this is true in both of the mouse
models of pancreas cancer. We then are in the
midst of performing a systemic metabolic analysis
of what metabolically is going wrong in these animals with
pancreas cancer. And one thing stood out very early
on in our metabolic analysis, in that
the mice with pancreas cancer had low serotonin
and high kynurenine. Okay, these are
shown here, and we've seen this in multiple models
of mouse models of cancer. Here's an example of the
same information from lung cancer, and it's also been
reported in patients with cancer.
So what does this mean? Well, this suggests that metabolically what's
happening in these mouse models of pancreas cancer
cachexia is a disruption in normal tryptophan
metabolism. So tryptophan can be
metabolized to generate serotonin.
It can be metabolized by the kynurenine
pathway to produce kynurenine and eventually NAD,
or it can be metabolized by the microbiome to produce
indoles. And our data was suggesting that from
the changes we were seeing in the tryptophan pathway was that
cachexia was driving
the pathway down the kynurenine
pathway and away from the serotonin pathway.
Why would that be important in cachexia?
Well, it could be very important because serotonin has an
important role in
preventing depression. And high
kynurenine has a role in muscle wasting and immune
suppression. So we thought that this metabolic
alteration in the tryptophan pathway might explain some
of the phenotypes we see in cancer cachexia.
And there are possible ways to intervene in this pathway.
We can provide a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor and increase serotonin levels and see if that
ameliorates a depression-like phenotype.
We can do the same by providing the metabolic substrate of
serotonin 5-HTP, or we can block kynurenine
production by using an IDO inhibitor.
And all of these
interventions produce the same phenotype, and I'll just show you the
results with the
SSRI.
And here you have an example of mice with PDAC,
with and without a serotonin reuptake inhibitor.
Here is food intake. The serotonin reuptake inhibitor
improves it, as well as it improves
pedestrian locomotion.
And this led us to the question, well, if the mice have an abnormal
tryptophan metabolism and they lack serotonin and they're depressed,
how do you tell if a mouse is depressed?
Okay, that's an important question for us.
And it turns out you can, because mice are good
swimmers,
and if the mouse is depressed, the mice
will just give up swimming. And so what we have here are
normal mice.
No tumor.
No tumor. And this is a PDAC mouse
with a tumor.And this is a pDEC mouse
with a tumor and an SSRI,
and you can see what happens is that what we've
done is that by correcting the defect in tryptophan
metabolism, we've cured the depression in the mice, and they keep
on swimming.
But then what happens to the wasting phenotype?
And you can see here that
with or without a serotonin reuptake inhibitor, there's no improvement
in body weight, fat mass, lean mass, or survival of the
animals. And so what that tells us is that the
disruption in the production of tryptophan
in pancreas cancer cachexia is
specifically affecting depression and
is completely independent from the wasting
phenotype. And so this is what we think.
In cancer, you have loss of
serotonin because tryptophan is being diverted down the kynurenine
pathway
by activation of IDO.
Okay. Oh, and one more important thing is that,
many cancer patients are depressed.
This suggests that there might be a biochemical basis for that
depression, and that needs to be addressed.
And kynurenine induction, it also contributes
to cachexia,
and
I'd have to talk about that at another time.
Okay, so what about identification of cancer cachexia
subtypes in humans? So one of the main goals of Team
CanCan was to
perform deep
phenotyping in cancer patients with cancer cachexia,
to understand what were the subtypes.
In other words, cancer cachexia is manifesting differently
in different patients. What are those subtypes?
And
we need to know because we need to treat,
if cancer cachexia is different in one patient from another, they need to be
treated differently. And this led to a
large clinical study,
UNCOVER, run out of Kaiser Permanente
in Northern California. And
the Lotus Study run out of the University of Rochester,
which collects patients through the NCORP program broadly across
the country. And this is run by the Cann and
Feliciano labs and the Dunn and Mussien labs.
And
what the purpose of this is, is to collect large samples
of blood, to analyze various
analytes as well as
what are potential indicators of
circulating indicators of cachexia.
To do questionnaires to find out if the
patients have fatigue, loss of appetite,
depression,
pain, insomnia, and so on, all
characteristics associated with cachexia.
And then to do physical tests to assess their
functionality. And when that was done, and this is
a collaboration between the UNCOVER
group and the Gonsalves lab,
they were able to discern two separate
groups of cachectic patients. So in red and
orange, these patients
both have active weight loss at baseline, but the
red patients have an inflammatory
signature and with high levels of GDF15, activin A,
IL6, and IL8. Okay?
But despite the fact that the orange patients are
still losing
significant weight, they lack this inflammatory
stress
phenotype. And also the red patients are the ones that have the most
symptoms of cancer cachexia, and that is missing
in the
orange patients.
And so that suggests there are at least two distinct
subtypes,
that manifest a different
phenotype in terms of
blood markers. And also if we follow the
survival of these patients, the patients
with the inflamed,
heavy symptom burden are the ones that
have a limited lifespan compared to the other group.
And then lastly, the Resnick Lab has been looking at
60,000 patients with cancer cachexia,
and mining the medical records of these patients.
And what he has found is that cancer cachexia is associated
with poor outcomes, low albumin and hemoglobin, high levels
of liver enzymes, but also tumors that have mutations in
p53. And he's gotten together with the
UNCOVER group and used his
algorithms to analyze the patient data that they've
collected from patient weights. And what they found
is that while some patients start losing weight and continue to
lose weight,
in other patients, cancer cachexia is dynamic.
They lose weight, they are weight stable, then they resume losing weight
again. Here you have a patient that started gaining weight and then
started losing weight again. So
in conclusionI think that what we've been able to
do in a relatively short period of time
in critical funding from the Cancer Grand Challenges, that we
wouldn't be able to do any of this without them, was identify
novel
brain tumor communication or tumor brain communication, rather,
define multiple metabolic drivers of cachexia, identify
new interventions, determine that symptoms define
subtypes with different prognosis, and establish a
new paradigm of cachexia as a dynamic
process. And all of this is by integrating animal
models with clinical data and back and forth.
This is an example of Team CanCan at our last
symposium at the University of Cambridge at St.
John's College. Everyone is happy and talking about
science. And then lastly,
if you're interested in cancer as a whole body
disease, this is a Cancer Grand Challenge conference that's coming up
in June at The Royal Society, and it should be absolutely wonderful.
Thank you.
Have a seat.
Okay. Eileen, thank you. That was tremendous.
Could I invite all the speakers to come up onto the stage and answer
questions if there are any?
So please, do come and ask questions, everybody.
Two microphones. Yes.
Right.
Okay. Right. Question over here first.
George Prendergast from Lankano.
I want to follow up with Eileen on the very interesting observations you made with
depression and IDO, the kynurenine pathway.
Due to the unfortunately flawed trial that Insight ran, we didn't get a
chance to see IDO perform as an inhibitor in cooperation with
PD-1, and that has yet to play in the story out.
But in that trial, there were a lot of anecdotal reports of depression being
mitigated.
Wow.
In fact, going back 20 years with indoximod, which is not a very good IDO
inhibitor, it's more a pathway inhibitor,
those were also seen in some of the trials.
So I think there may be today a compound sitting in Insight's
barrels not doing anything, where there might be something that could be
actionable.
Wow.
Those trials didn't reach IC50 and had the wrong patient populations in
phase three, which has not been widely reported.
But they were effective if you look into the data a bit, and this behavioral
effect, I think, might be of great interest to your group.
Oh, that's fantastic. And in fact, I think that one of the things we've
been thinking about is that, now we can assay for a
biochemical phenotype of depression,
looking at metabolites and loss of
serotonin. So that's really great.
I'd like to catch up with you and learn more about that.
Do you think that the brain is the source of some of the other phenotypes?
You seemed to allude to that in your intro a bit.
Yeah.
But serotonin can be produced elsewhere in the body, so I think
a lot of it is happening in the brain, but I don't want to make the claim
that that's where everything is happening, because we just don't know.
Thanks.
Okay, Jeff.
Really interesting work across the board.
I want to congratulate all of you on what you're doing.
This question is mostly about the Mutagraphs work.
I was wondering how you might follow up,
because all of the work you've done so far has been about the mutations
that are hitting the genome, not necessarily the mutations that
are actually causing cancer.
So how have you thought about following up to try to figure out what the connection
between those two are?
Yes. So, well,
there are two significant challenges if one
tries to investigate all this through the signatures.
The first is, how do you go from a signature to the agent?
And the second is, does the presence of mutations with a
particular signature increase cancer risk?
So,
the
best example we have of the latter
is following up on the
results from the colorectal cancer and the colibactin story.
And it's really adopting ordinary
epidemiological practice,
that in the first, that the highest level you can go before you
use
interventions is to do some form of case control study.
So that is going to be done by
having biopsies of normal colon
from individuals with cancer and biopsies of normal
colon from individuals without cancer.
And those two groups will have to be matched in all other ways.
The biopsies will have to be taken more or less in the same
time, same ages
same place, very important.
And then to look in those biopsies,
those normal colon biopsies, to see the degree of
colibactin mutations that are
present. So if there are more, if there's a higher prevalence of
colibactin mutagenesis in individuals with cancer or a higher burden
of colibactin mutations in individuals with cancer compared to
those without, that's the sort of standard case control
way of looking at that. So those
studies are underway, putting together the sets of
individuals, collecting them. It's not so straightforward because
there is international variation and
making those studies as well matched as possible is going to be
challenging. So that's the way we're going about it and in
a pretty systematic a way as we can
for the colibactin space.
So in the specific colibactin case, you know what mutations are actually
... caused by the colibactin.
And there are some understanding of what mutations actually lead
to the cancers that are resulting.
So is there some way to--
Have you thought about connecting those in a more computational rather than
experimental fashion?
Well,
one thing we can do is to look at whether we find the
colibactin signature in key
genes that are involved in colorectal cancer in
oncogenesis. And the
one that recommends itself for looking at that is APC, because it's
right at the beginning of the process of
carcinogenesis for the colon.
And the answer is that we can see the
colibactin signature in indels
in APC, in those cases
where
the signature is present, you can see it in the APC gene.
The base substitution signature doesn't register there very well,
and the reason for that is that
the base substitution signature is predominantly T to C, and T
to C mutations don't generate stop codons, and stop codons is what
APC needs. So if the whole hypothesis is correct,
colibactin should be working on APC to
generate colorectal cancer through indels.
Thank you. Thank you, Mike. Yes, here and then
Carlo.
Anton Hansen from Team eDynamic. I've also a question for Mike
regarding tumor promotion. You mentioned that most of the
carcinogens are, or some of the carcinogens are not mutagenic, but
some of those are also un-eugenic in the sense that they promote chromosomal
instability.
Mm-hmm.
So how much of the tumor promotion is really caused by true promotion, and
how much of that can be explained by induction of some chromosomal instability,
you think?
Do you want to look at that?
Well, yeah, I can
address that.
What has been shown
is that if you use promoters to
induce tumors as a major component of the tumor induction process, you
don't see a major increase in point mutational burden.
You do see some reactive oxygen SBS18, some of
the signatures that Ludmil and Mike have characterized.
So there's some level of increase there.
We see that mainly in genes
involved in late stage progression rather than early
stages.
But I do think that
your chromosome instability is an important point for the simple
reason that these promoters, you're hammering mice
twice a week with this. It's causing constant proliferation, constant
stress,
DNA replication. Aneuploidy is a common event
anytime cells divide. So one in 100 cell divisions, I think, is
the odd chromosome that goes off in the wrong direction.
And what we see with the skin model is that
these proliferating cells
go through several cell states, which we think are
sequentially being stabilized by an
aneuploidy event. So H RAS is on chromosome 7.
The earliest event that we see in papillomas that
being promoted by TPA is a trisomy of chromosome
7. Right? The second event we see is a
trisomy of chromosome 6, and we know that H RAS is on
7, K RAS is on 6. Those two trisomies work together
to, we think, stabilize that cell state, so that
state then can progress to the next state.
And there are two other common trisomies that we see in this simple model.
So I think you're absolutely right, but it's not like promoters
cause genomic instability. It's promoters cause
inflammation and proliferation, and it's a consequence of a
natural selection of events that enable the cell states to progress.
Thank you.
Thanks, Alan. Carlo and then Howard.
Hey, Carlo Maley from Arizona State.
Really exciting work, and particularly I'm excited by the colibactin result that
you have, Mike. It's because it seems so modifiable.
Would it be possible to vaccinate against colibactin just to select against the
microbes that are expressing it?
I don't know the answer to that question, but it's plausible.
If the hypothesis is shown to be correct, there are a number of approaches that
could be taken to prevention. One, you've just
suggested.
The second is that
quite a lot of children get their microbiome or get their
colibactin-producing bug from their mother.
So it would be possible to screen the mother's microbiome before the
baby's born, and those
mothers that have got it to somehow eradicate it in that way.
But there is a wider problem. All of those, that set
of approaches are long-term, but there's a problem if it's true,
that faces us now, which is that, as I said,
40% of children born in the UK in the last-
In the UK, yeah
... 20 years have been exposed.
Mm-hmm.
So
for that, one might
imagine some way of
sampling the colon, the rectum, and the colibactin
signature is more prominent on the left side and is strongest in the
rectum, so that is helpful. In some
population-based way, by brushing or something of that nature,
to see whether an individual has got the signature.
And if that was possible, over time one could build up
risk profiles for how much of the colibactin signature you
have and how much risk that adds.
And if one finds that people are in the high-risk category, then
oneOne could do that sort of screening at quite an early age, at the
age of 20 or 30, and offer them a much earlier
colonoscopy. That's the sort of set of approaches.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mike. Howard.
Hi, Howard Chang, Team eDynamics. This is a question also for Dr. Stratton.
So you highlighted a point that among these now earlier onset
colorectal cancer, there's an enrichment of the colibactin signature, but that
accounts for a third. Does that mean that there are two thirds of these
cases that's not caused by any mutagenic or
genetic mechanism that we can detect?
Well, first of all, there are limits to the detection of the
colibactin signature in cancers.
So that third could be higher than a third.
Right.
The
other signatures could also be contributing, but if we're talking about exogenous
exposures, then it would look like to us that there's about
a third to a half maybe of
colorectal cancers in which we can detect a mutational signature that
is likely to be an exogenous exposure.
That doesn't exclude exogenous exposures in contributing to the
rest of the early onset cases. It's just not being detected
by the mutational signature approach.
So it could be epigenetic changes
or other things of that nature.
Great. Thank you.
Okay. Question here, and then-
Sebastian Mueller from Technical University Munich.
My question is to Dr. Stratton and Dr. Birney.
So you nicely showed that the whole body is full of mutations,
oncogenic mutations and clones that have these mutations, but the rate
limiting step is the promotion. So when we think of
cancer prevention,
wouldn't it be the most reasonable way to interfere with this
promotion, and is that actually possible, or is it
simply too stochastic and diverse that we can not really
do that?
Maybe I should.
Okay.
Yeah. So
what you've just said is exactly the basis for this prominent
Cancer Grand Challenge. The purpose of which is to understand
promotion as a means of getting to strategies for
prevention, and there are many ways that we can begin
to think about that.
So understanding the specific mechanisms of
promoters, we can intervene at
different stages. We can now monitor early stages of clonal
expansion. You can see this in mice models.
You can begin to see it also in human populations.
PROMINENT is carrying out a series of intervention trials.
This is work led by Mark Gunter, and Nuria
Lopez-Bigas is working with Mark,
to look at
smoking cessation, for example, or bariatric surgery,
to prevent obesity and look at clonal development under
these conditions in human populations.
In the mouse, we're also trying to do these kinds of things by monitoring
the clonal expansion at different stages, looking at the effects of stopping the
promotion in the middle. I did show one slide, I probably went through it very
quickly, but there's evidence that when you stop promotion,
then some of the clones that are already there actually grow faster.
I didn't have time to go into the details, but clearly, there's a
constant
balance between these selective constraints in allowing various
clones to grow or making them disappear.
So I think the answer is yes, but exactly how that's going to happen, we don't
know. We've identified some populations of immune
cells that appear to be essential, we think, for promotion.
Charlie Swanton's original work in Nature identified
interleukin-1 beta
in myeloid cells as an interesting target.
So you can think about ways to target these specific cytokines
or the cells that result from exposure to these
cytokines, the whole range of things, and these are the central
questions for PROMINENT.
We've got six minutes, so we're going to have to have three quick
questions. So we have to-
Sure
... hard stop at 7:00.
I have two question about the cachexia.
Number one, you mentioned the high fat does not improve the
cachexia kind of nutrition. Do you try any other study
about high protein or,
for example, beta-hydroxybutyrates?
Any other nutrition profile can improve that?
I think the second question is-
We just have one question because we've got three other people in the room.
The answer is that people have tried a lot of dietary interventions,
and
I would say that the results so far are not encouraging.
Thanks.
And so the question is that we know what makes it
worse. What we really need is something that makes it go away.
We've got time. We'll have your other question.
Hi there. I was thinking about the interaction between PROMINENT and
Mutagraphs,
and whether there might be,
in the absence of any evidence that colibactin is becoming more common
over the last 50 years, whether there might be other promoting agents,
microplastics being potentially the most obvious one, that might be interacting
in the colon.
I can address the first part of that, which is,
when you say in the absence of any evidence that colibactin- I don't know the
evidence, sorry.
Yeah. Well, that's one of the questions to address,
and
that's being done as well. So there could have been an increase.
Mm-hmm.
It's slightly challenging to show that but-
Yeah
... because one has to go back 70, 80 years in time, but we're looking for
that.There is some evidence from mouse models,
not from our studies as yet,
suggesting that exposure to microplastics does increase
inflammation in the gastric tract and increases incidence
of stomach cancer in mice, for example.
Mm-hmm.
But there is definitely evidence that it can have an
inflammatory effect. We'd expect that these
microplastics are probably like inert particles in some way,
and that they're perturbing the normal ecosystem in the gut.
So I think they're very good candidates.
And the question about colibactin is also
the extent to which... Clearly, the bacterium is there, and it's
strongly linked to this
disease.
And you just alluded to this question that came up
earlier. Those mutations, it's great to see them.
They're definitely telling us that there is exposure.
But as yet, we still need to find out more about the causative nature in
terms of causing mutations that drive the tumors.
APC is one candidate.
But it's also a bacterium, so it causes inflammation.
So it's going to be causing all these ancillary phenotypes linked to
promotion. So maybe it's like smoking, and it's doing both.
Yeah. I was wondering that. Yes.
Thank you.
Yes. Mark Vinson from Western University, Canada.
Wondering what the colibactin is assisting the bacteria if it's
carrying around this extra baggage to make it.
Is it mutating its competitors, and
that's how it mutates the colon? And are these tumors that arise
more immunogenic because they maybe have a higher TMB?
Well, I think your presumption about why the E.
coli has the extra 50 kb is probably correct.
It's trying to outgun its competition in the
microbial community of the
colon.
I don't know of any evidence for the
direct question you've asked as to whether these tumors that have got the
colibactin signature are more immunogenic.
I don't
know of any evidence in favor of that.
Or against it.
Or against it, yes.
Fair. Okay. Well, we've got one last question from me, if that's okay, Mike.
Philosophical question. How does one begin to,
for example, establish
carcinogens that may be driving
geographical disparities in disease like esophageal cancer in the absence of a
clear mutagenic signature? What would be the next step to,
if you had another 20 million, what would you do to now
establish a non-mutational cause or
promoter in esophageal carcinoma, for example?
Yes.
Well, Alan could also address it, but I think it is a more
difficult challenge.
Yeah.
The fact is that picture that I showed of the clones
in the esophagus,
that's a highly variable picture.
You don't need very many human beings to show how variable it is.
People of the same age can differ between the number of clones they have and the
size of the clones. There's a lot of variation in there.
And
so what one can do is measure that variation.
The
sequencing technology is available to do that, as you know,
and so one can put in place the sort of epidemiological
measurements.
Yeah.
And I think that may lead to finding
a variation that is more of those
clones in individuals who have got esophageal cancer than
people who have not.
Yeah.
Your direct question is how do you go back from that to the agent?
And that's more difficult to do with that sort of
data than from the mutational signature data.
Yeah.
You can see your way through to it with the mutational signature data.
But-
Yeah
... those landscapes of clones, it's much more difficult.
Yeah. It's a fascinating problem, isn't it?
Can I just-
Yes.
... a few seconds because this is directly relevant to what's going on now
in Prominent.
Yeah.
So obviously, the tumors that were sequenced by
Sanger from the IARC, they have collected normal tissue
from all of these patients
as well as
very extensive epidemiological data on their exposure.
So for example, these kidneys that were sequenced, the tumors were sequenced, all
of those normal kidneys are there.
They've been digitally scanned.
Paul's group with Nuria are looking in great detail at these tissue scans.
In parallel, we have kidney tumors in mice
induced by the 20 chemicals, and some of those chemicals induce kidney cancer.
Mm-hmm.
We've just scanned 600 kidneys, normal
kidneys from mice that got these tumors
induced by any one of the 20 different chemicals.
And we're using various approaches to try to
understand the mechanisms that lead from a chemical exposure
to the pathology that leads to
the emergence of the tumor. So I think there are ways we can begin to
explore the direct effects of chronic exposure to each different
chemical and look for parallels.
Yeah.
Both across chemicals but also across tissues.
Yeah. That makes sense. Super. And I think on that note, we're going to have to
draw this session to a close. I'd like to thank, first of all,
not just all our speakers who gave wonderful talks. Very grateful to you.
But I also want to thank our additional funders, that you can see on the screen
here,
for all of their generous contributions to making this initiative possible and for
all the research you heard today. And invite you all for a drink outside now
to talk further and challenge the speakers a little bit more over a
glass of wine. Thank you.
So
there's
probably
some-